a month ago this family from north
london flew from heathrow to a wedding
in kabul they were due to return on
monday
instead they're stranded peering from a
window in fear the taliban outside
[Music]
did you try to go to the airport
yeah i was trying but just when we mean
when we saw that they killed the people
and just we ran away
and our kids was really scared and they
just start crying
how old are your children
one of them is two years old and another
one is eight years old what's been your
communication with the british
government have everybody trying to help
you together
at all i just keep trying call them and
just they said you have to wait you have
to do it
brothers were married this month and 11
british members of the family attended
they are all stuck in an apartment in
the afghan capital when they tried to
leave their car was taken by force
they said you have to give me the key i
said why i said my it's my own car it's
not the government's car i said they
said we don't bother we don't care who
you are and just they put the gun on my
head
and they took the car then i said okay
this is
you can take it
several british families have shared
footage with us from relatives who are
trapped in the country witnessing the
return of armed men and strict laws
women can't leave home without a man
meaning for maria's sister who lives in
an all-female household
she and no one else can go out not even
to buy food
but that is not true
they are walking in this on the streets
with the guns and they are firing
we have been locked
at home since four or five days
and we are not allowed to go outside
in your own country in your home omlan
you can't get out of your house
alone a girl a woman
because there's no man
i don't know where's the human right
where's the woman right
but abdul who runs a laundrette in
london and also has family in
afghanistan says western governments
have no choice now but to work with the
taliban and they have to help them the
way they help the previous government
became engaging with the with the
taliban not for the sake of taliban for
the sake of afghan people because afghan
people is not deserving to be isolated
these are crucial days for those trying
to get out and those who can't
waiting to see what will become of their
country
jason farrell sky news